five common signs of iron deficiency and
five iron-rich foods to include in your
diet iron is a vital mineral that plays
a crucial role in the production of red
blood cells and transportation of oxygen
throughout the body iron deficiency is
extremely common in females here are 5
common signs of iron deficiency feeling
tired and lacking energy even after
adequate rest pale skin and lips due to
reduced hemoglobin levels shortness of
breath even after mild activity brittle
nails or spoon shaped nails and
uncomfortable Sensations in the legs
especially at night also known as
restless leg syndrome iron-rich foods to
include in your diet lean red meat like
beef lamb and liver are excellent
sources of heme iron dark leafy greens
like spinach kale and swiss card provide
non-heem iron legumes and lentils like
chickpeas and kidney beans also offer a
good amount of iron fortified cereals
enriched with iron can be included in
your diet to boost your intake pumpkin
seeds are also a rich source of iron
remember to stay curious and stay
healthy